ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้เยี่ยมสวัสดีครับนัก
เรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนอ้าวันนี้เรากลับ
มาเจอกันนะครับในช่องคอมเพลงเอาไทยด้วย
ครับ Bieber ทางเจอกับเพื่อให้ค่ะเจอกับ
น้องรีเรียมเย้เย้ๆแล้วค่ะที่เป็น
ยังไงบ้างคะวันนี้อ้าเฮียตี้สบายดีครับ
วันนี้อ้าวันนี้วันนี้เอ๊ยเออวันนี้
วันนี้ที่เราคุยกันเป็นวันอะไรคะวันนี้
ที่เรามาคุยกันพรุ่งนี้วันอังคารครับ
วันอังคาร
R8  E ขอลบก่อนนะพี่ยังไม่ได้ลบแน่โอเค
เอาวันนี้วันนี้ว่างตั้งคานครับอานามิวัน
อังคารวันอังคารไปค่ะวันอังคารวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะอ้าวันอังคารวันที่ 8 ครับวันนี้
หน้าวันที่ 8 ใช้ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือน
มีนาคมครับ
มีนาคม
5 ใช้ครับวันอังคารที่ 8 เดือนมีนาคม
คศอะไรคะเที่ยน่าข้อ 2
ต.ค. 22 ครับถ้า
กลับ 2,000 บาทปี
พตอะไรค่ะวิธีผช
2565 ครับอ่ะ
ปี
2565 เป็นปี
2022 ใช่แล้วปีที่แล้วหรอคะ 5 ปีที่แล้ว
ใช่ไหมครับปีที่แล้วเคปีที่แล้วก็เป็นปี
2010  21 ครับ
อ้าปีที่แล้วนี่ปีที่แล้ว 2,000  21
เราปีนี้
2022 หาใช่ค่ะมิน่าล่ะคะปีหน้าใช่ไหมปี
หน้าก็จะต้องเป็นปี
3/55 ปีหน้า
ครับแล้วถ้าเป็นอีก 2 ปีข้างหน้า
อีก 2 ปีห้าใช่ไหมสองเองข้างหน้านี้คือ 1
ปีข้างหน้าแล้วก็สองปีข้างหน้าก็ต้องเป็น
ปี
2024 ครับอ่าอีก 2 ปีข้างหน้าง่า 2024
ครับ
แล้วตอนนี้ตี้กับเรียนคุยกันอยู่กี่
โมงราคา 5 ตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้นะตอน
นี้4โมงครับ
ตีโมง 4 โมง 4 โมงตรงสี่โมงตรง
ตรงตอนเย็นไหมครับ
5 งงโอเคฟ้าเก้า
เรียมเรียมได้ยินเพียงพี่พูดถึงหนังอ่ะ
ใช่ครับเรื่อง
อ่ะเดี๋ยววันนี้เราจะมันเล่าเรื่องหนัง
ให้นักเรียนฟังกันนะไอ้หน้าหนังเรื่องนี้
พี่ว่า
ครับหนังที่พี่อ่ะพี่ชอบอ้าใช่ครับเป็น
หนังที่เรียมชอบเวียงก็ชอบน่ะเพื่อที่จะ
ชอบนะครับพี่คิดว่านักเรียนก็ชอบเหมือน
กันนะอ่าใช่โอเค
อาบคือหนังเรื่องอะไรคะอ้าหนังเรื่องอะ
เรื่องนี้ครับนี่เม็ดที่มีรูปให้ดูเรื่อง
นี้น้องเรียมจำจำหนังเรื่องนี้ได้ไหมจำ
เรื่องนี้ได้ไหม
จำได้ค่ะอ๋อถ้าน้องเรียมจำได้หนังเรื่อง
นี้เรื่องอะไรครับเรื่องอะไรนั่งเรื่อง
Frozen
r-flow เซนไซครับโอเคอ่าจำหนังเรื่องนี้
แล้วจำชื่อจ้าผมชื่อของสองคนนี้ได้ไหม
ครับจำได้ไหม
จำได้ค่ะถ้าจำได้อ๋ออ๋อครับผมอ่ะคนนี้คน
นี้ชื่ออะไรครับ
ชื่ออ๋อคนที่เปียผงอ้าคนที่มีผมก็ไม่คะ
หน้ามีผมเปียนี้ใช่ไหมผมเปียสีสีทองคนนี้
ชื่อชื่ออะไรครับ
ชื่อ and นาน่าใช่แล้วคนนี้ชื่อแอนนานะ
ครับแล้วอีกคนหนึ่งอีกคนนึงชื่ออะไรครับ
อ่อนอีกคนนึงที่ใกล้กันหน้าอีกคนที่
เอลซ่าอ้าชื่อเอลซ่าใช่ครับอีกคนหนึ่ง
ชื่อเอลซ่านะครับเอลซ่าเป็นอิฐเป็นพี่ของ
แม่หัว
หน้าชายครับแอนนาเป็นน้องหน้าซ้ายครับ
เหมือนพี่อาร์ตี้
ก็เป็นพี่อาจเป็นพี่ของเป็นน้องห้าแสน
ครับเตรียมก็เป็นน้องแอนนาแอนนาก็เป็น
หนองห่าโอเค
เราแค่ตีคะเรียงได้ยินบางคนก็พูดว่า
โปรเส้นเป็นหนังบางคนก็พูดว่าเอาเส้นเป็น
การ์ตูนอ๋อใช่ครับ 5 เป็นการ์ตูนด้วย
เหมือนกันใช้ครับเพราะว่าเพราะว่า So
send ทั้งแอนนาแล้วก็เอลซ่าไม่ใช่คนจริง
ๆไม่ใช่คนเป็นการ์ตูนที่วาดขึ้นมาว่าขึ้น
มาน้าเป็นการ์ตูนปาร์ตี้เป็นคนจริงๆ 5
size เขาเพียงติ๊ดเป็นคนเดี๋ยวขออ่าน
น้องเรียมก็เป็นคนคนไหนครับส่วนแอนนากับ
เอลซ่าไม่ได้เป็นคนเป็นการ์ตูน
ขอการ์ตูนที่วาดๆที่วาดขึ้นมาขึ้นมา
ครับๆเอลซ่า
ครับการ์ตูนได้เรียกว่าหนังการ์ตูนก็ได้
ใช่วันนี้พี่จะมันเล่าเรื่องเรื่องเรื่อง
ของหนังการ์ตูนเรื่อง Frozen เรื่องนี้
โอเค
ครับๆก่อนที่เป็นเด็กๆตอนที่เร็วซ่าแล้ว
ก็ and นาเป็นเด็กทั้งสองคนทั้งสองคนอยู่
กับพ่ออยู่กับแม่น่าอยู่ด้วยกันกับพ่อ
แล้วก็แม่นะครับหากได้เอวสาวนะครับเอลซ่า
มีพลังวิเศษ 5 มีพลังวิเศษ
นี้พลังวิเศษถ้าเราวิเศษๆครับก็คือก็คือ
สามารถเสกที่มะได้เสกิมะได้ 5 นี่สิมะนะ
เศรษฐีมะได้หน้าเอลซ่ามีคะนี่เอลซ่า up
อ่ะมีอยู่วันนึงทั้งสองคนเล่นด้วยกันเล่น
ด้วยกันแล้วเอลซ่าเศรษฐีมะเศรษฐีมะไปถูก
and นาไปถูกแอนนาจะให้ทำให้อาณาตัวเย็น
ตัวเย็น
ตัวเย็นแต่ไม่ตายๆตัวเย็นหนาวเขาว่าหิมะ
ไม่ตายครับไม่ตายเพราะว่าหิมะเย็นหิมะ
เย็นใช่ไหมครับหน้าเย็น and หน้าก็เลยตัว
ไอเย็นน้าจากนั้นเมื่อโดนอา
กิมเต็มที่เอลซ่าเสกมาโดนนาพ่อกับแม่พ่อ
กับแม่ก็พาพาพาแอนนาไปหาไปหาโทรโทรที่
เป็นอ่ะอ่าก้อนหินนะครับหาแต่มีชีวิตนะ
ครับช่วยรักษาช่วยรักษาแอนนาน้า
ชายครับน้องก็หลังจากนั้นไม่สบายๆอันนำ
ไม่สบายเพราะอนาคตบ่อยเย็นตัวเย็นหน้าตัว
เย็นจากที่
เวทมนตร์ของเอลซ่าทำให้อันนาตัวเย็นก็พ่อ
กับแม่ก็พาแอนนามา
มหาโทเพื่อช่วยรักษาให้อันนาหายหน้าหอ
ธรรมแล้วจากนั้นก็พ่อก็เลยพ่อก็เลยบอกว่า
บอกว่าต่อไปไม่ให้สองคนมาเล่นด้วยกันเขา
ไม่ให้เล่นด้วยกัน
ๆเพราะๆกลัวกลัวว่าเอลซ่าจะทำให้แอนนาตัว
เย็นอีก
อาขอตายครับเอลซ่าแอนนาพ่อบอกไม่ให้มา
อยู่ด้วยกันให้อยู่ด้วยกันให้อยู่คนละ
ห้องอาอยู่คนละห้อง
อาหาๆแล้วก็ต่อมาต่อมาเมื่ออ่าพ่อกับแม่
นะครับเดินทางออกไป
อ่าในทะเลแล้วเกิดอุบัติเหตุในคะออกไป
ทะเล
High แล้วเรือ
ล่มเรือล่มลงไปในทะเลจมลงไปในทะเล
อ๋ออาเรือแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะพี่อาร์ตี้อ้าใช่
ครับเรือ
เนื้อ
หาก็คือลงไปในทะเลๆครับจมลงไปในทะเล
หากแล้วพ่อกับแม่ก็อ่าๆ
อาก็เหลือแต่แอนนากับเอลซ่า
ตามลำพังอยู่ที่อายุที่วางอ่านอยู่ในวาง
ในทั้งวางได้ครับออกไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ๆบ้านใช่
ไหมคะพี่อาจจะไม่ใช่บ้านอ่าพระราชาอะพ่อ
กับแม่ของแอนนาเป็นพระราชาเป็นพระราชินี
อยู่ในวังน่ะไม่ได้อยู่บ้านใช่ครับเพราะ
อันนี้คือพ่อ
ข้อของแอนนากับเอซ่าอา
พ่อเป็นคือแม่ใช่ครับ
ขอก็คือพ่อเป็นพระราชา
A5  size ขับ
โอ้ว
เท่าไหร่อยู่ที่ที่วางไม่ได้อยู่ที่บ้าน
สว่างบ้านหลังหน่อยเตรียมก็
ตายครับถ้าเป็นเรียงกูก็อยู่ที่บ้านหาใช้
เขาว่าอะราชา
พระราชา
มีบ้านที่เรียกว่าวังๆใส่ครับน้า
แล้วข้อกับแม่ตายแล้วทำยังไงค่ะพี่ถ้า
ทั้งแอนนาแล้วก็เอลซ่าก็อยู่ด้วยกันสองคน
นะครับอ่ะแต่ว่าพอพอๆกับแม่ตายแล้วนะครับ
อ่ะอาร์เอ็นซ่าก็จะต้องกลายมาเป็นพระ
ราชินีแทน
เพราะว่าขอโอ๊ย
ลูกก็เป็นเจ้าหญิงพ่อตายลูกก็ขึ้นมาเป็น
พระราชินี
อ๋ออันนี้คือเอลซ่าใช่ไหมคะไปครับเอลซ่า
แอกซ่าก็เลยเป็นค่ะลาชินีเอลซ่าก็เป็นพระ
ราชินีแทนพ่อมันครับอ๋อ
แล้ว
เกิดอะไรขึ้นค่ะอย่าถ้าเกิดอะไรขึ้นอ่า
ตอนที่อ่า
เป็นเอลซ่าเป็นพระราชินีนะครับแอนนาก็โต
ขึ้น Anna ก็ไปชอบกับผู้ชายคนนึงชอบกับ
ผู้ชายคนนึงนะใช่ครับ
เอลซ่าก็มาชอบกับคนนี้นะครับผู้ชายคนนี้
ชื่อคอนหน้าม้าชอบกับพรแล้วเอะแอนนาอยาก
ที่จะแต่งงานกับฮ้อนนะอานาก็ไปบอกไปบอก
เอลซ่าบอกว่าขอแต่งงานกับฮ้อนอ่ะเนาะแต่ง
งานให้ทำเลยนะงานบ้านใช่ครับแต่งงานกับ
คอนและห้อง rl ซ่าไม่ไม่อนุญาตไม่ให้แต่ง
เอลซ่าไม่ให้แต่งตายเดี๋ยวซ่าก็เลยโกรธ
ตายเอลซ่าโกรธมากเอลซ่าโกรธล็อคทำยังไงคะ
อ่ะเอลซ่าโกรธมากหากความโกรธของเอลซ่าก็
เลยทำให้เมื่อกวางทั้งวันวางทั้งวันกลาย
เป็นน้ำแข็ง
อากโรจน์มากก็เลยทำให้วังทั้งวางตายเป็น
น้ำแข็งหมดเลยต้นไม้เป็นน้ำแข็งหน้าวาง
เป็นน้ำแข็งหมดเลยหน้าอ่อนก็เลยนะอ่าหาว
หนาวชายหน้าหนาว
เพียบปีค่ะเรียนจำได้ว่าเราคุยกันว่า
แอนนาไม่สบาย
สบายหาแต่ทำไมเรียนเห็น and นาออกไปเดิน
เดินๆเดินเล่นข้างนอกขอแอนนาหายแล้วแน่น
นะหายแล้วตอนที่แอนนาพ่อกับแม่พาไปหาโทร
พาไปหาโชว์ครับ
ฮ่าๆ
มาหาโชว์โทรก็รักษาให้แอนนาหาย 555 เพราะ
หายแล้วพ่อหายแล้วพ่อก็เลยไม่ให้เล่นด้วย
กันให้แยกกันอยู่
ตายฮ่าๆๆ
โอเคอ้าที่เอลซ่าโกรธใช่ไหมไม่ไม่ให้ไม่
ให้แอนนาแต่งงาน M สร้างมีบทก็เลยทำให้
วางทั้งวันกลายเป็นน้ำแข็งอาเมืองก็กลาย
เป็นน้ำแข็งชายจากนั้นเอลซ่าก็
หนีออกมาอยู่ข้างนอกอ้ะไปอยู่บนภูเขาอ๋อ
ได้ครับเตรียมเห็นเอลซ่าวิ่งๆวิ่งหาใช้
ครับขึ้นไปบนภูเขาได้เอลซ่าก็ขึ้นไปอยู่
บนภูเขาแล้วก็ก็ใช้อ่าเวทมนตร์เสกปราสาท
บนภูเขาเป็นปราสาทน้ำแข็ง
ใช่ครับ
เสร็จแล้วเสร็จแล้วแอนนาแอนนาที่อยู่ใน
วางในวังหนาวในวังหนาวมากใช่ครับอ่ะทุกคน
ทุกๆคนที่อยู่ในวังก็หนาว
อะนาก็เลยคิดแทนนาก็เลยคิดคิดที่จะไปขอ
ตามไปตามเอลซ่ากลับมากลับไปอยู่ในวางแล้ว
ทำให้วางไม่หนาว
งู
ในครับหมูตักนะแล้วจากนั้นครับหน้าจาก
นั้นแอนนาก็ออกไปตามที่สาวนะครับออกไปตาม
เอลซ่านะครับในระหว่างทางระหว่างทางที่
เดินทางไปนะครับเดินทางไปก็ไปเจอกับควาง
ไปเจอกับ R มนุษย์หิมะอ้านี่มนุษย์นะฮะไป
ครับหน้าเราก็มีเอาไปเจอกับผู้ชายอีกคน
นึงไปเจอกับผู้ชายอีกคนหนึ่งที่พากันนะ
ครับไปตามหาเอลซ่าด้วยกันนะครับ 5 ผู้ชาย
คนนี้ชื่อสตีฟนะครับพากันมีสตีฟวางแล้วก็
มีมนุษย์หิมะไปด้วยกันไปตามเอลซ่าปรับ
มาร์ท
มาแล้วแอนนากับสติชอะไป
ตามเอลซ่ากลับมาได้ค่ะอ้าก็อ่ะตอนที่ไป
ถึงนี่เอลซ่ามาถึงประสาทของ 5 แอนนา Mask
ขายของเอลซ่าแล้วนะครับเอลซ่าก็ไม่ยอม
กลับไม่ยอมกลับไปอ้าใช่ครับทั้งคู่ก็เลย
ทะเลาะกันทะเลาะกัน and นายอยากให้กลับ
เอลซ่าไม่อยากกลับไม่กลับไม่กลับชายแล้ว
เอลซ่าก็เลยอ่าเสกเวทมนตร์ไปถูกแอนนาหน้า
ทำให้แอนนาจ่ายเป็นตัวเย็นอีก
น้าาแล้วน่กันนี่คือเศษใช่ไหมคะครับเศษ
ขนาดตายเป็นตู้เย็นเพราะตัวเองไม่อยาก
กลับ
ไปครับหัวหน้าเพราะแอนนาตัวใหญ่ครับ
R  R ตัวเย็นชายครับแล้วสัตว์ใหญ่ค่ะพี่
สตีฟ speak ก็เลยก็เลยไปไปหาไปหาโทรสตีฟ
ไปถามโทรหาทำยังไงทำยังไงให้แอนนาหายนะ
ครับน้า
โทรก็บอกว่า 6 ตอบโทรก็บอกว่า and น่าจะ
หายได้ถ้าถ้าอาจารย์ได้เจอกับรักแท้
อ่าถ้าได้เจอกับรักแท้แกสตีฟสตีฟก็เลยรัก
แท้หาใช่ครับเป็นรักแท้ๆความรักที่ดีๆๆ
ใช่ครับสตีฟก็เลยคิดว่าถ้าเป็นรักแท้ก็
ต้องเป็นคนที่เอนนายอยากจะแต่งงานด้วย
อ้าก็คือขอพรก็คือคอน
ให้ครับสตีฟก็เลยพาพา
ฮ้อนให้ผ้า Anna พายนากลับไปหาหอน
ห่าใช่ครับกลับไปที่กลับไปที่วังที่หนาว
หนาว
หน้าใช่ครับแล้วคอนคือรักแท้ของแอนนาไหม
คะพ่อกลับมาพอสปี๊ดภาแอนนากลับมาหาฮอรพร
ก็บอกว่าคอนจะไม่ช่วยแอนนา
on จะไม่ช่วยเท่าไรไม่ได้รักแอนนา
ที่นาอ้าวพี่ฮอลล์ที่ฮอลล์จะแต่งงานกับ
แอนนาเพราะคอนอยากจะเป็นเจ้าชาย
ของเมืองนี้
อ่ะแต่ไม่ได้รักคอนไม่ได้รักแอนนา
แต่ถ้าไม่ได้รักคนดับ
ยาวอยากดาวชายดาวชายอ่าใช่ครับแต่ไม่ได้
รักมาก
[เพลง]
ๆครับ 5 อ่ะยาเสียใจไหมคะร้องไห้เลยให้
สบายเฮ็ดนางส่วยเย็นอาหาร
ไม่รู้ and  Now ไม่รู้อ่ะไอ้นาก็เลยไม่
หายน้ำไม่หายอ่ะพอทุกคนตับมาที่วังน่ะ
เอลซ่าก็กลับมา Steve ก็กลับมาที่วังเจอ
กับฮ้อนฮ้อนไม่ช่วยอ่อนไม่ช่วยอ่ะพรก็เลย
ต่อสู้กับแอนนาไอ้ต่อสู้กับเอลซ่าสู้กัน
อ่ะต่อสู้กับเอลซ่าเพราะว่าเพราะว่าคอน
อยากเป็นพระราชาอยากได้วางนะครับหน้าแต่
ตอนที่สู้อัน
นี้คือเอลซ่าเอลซ่าเอลซ่ากำลังกำลังจะโดน
ฮอลล์ใช้ดาบใช้ดาบฟันอ่ะแปะแอนนาแอนนา
เข้ามาขวางไว้เข้ามาขวางไว้
ได้ครับตอนนี้แอนนากำลังจะกลายเป็นน้ำ
แข็งแล้วเพราะแอนนาตัวเย็นมาตั้งนานแล้ว
ยังไม่มีใครช่วยยังไม่ยังไม่เจอกับรักแท้
ถ้า
แล้วตอนที่
นะครับหน้าตอนที่ตอนที่
คอนกำลังจะใช้มีดฟันเข้าไปที่อันนา at
Nut กลายเป็นน้ำแข็งกลายเป็นน้ำแข็งไป
แล้วนะครับหน้าแล้วเอลซ่าก็เลยเข้ามาช่วย
เข้ามาช่วยแอนนานะครับแล้วความรักความรัก
ของแอนนากับที่รักกับอ่า
เอลซ่าอะความรักของทั้งคู่ความรักของพี่
และน้องทำให้นานาหายอีกครั้งหนึ่งอ๋อๆๆๆ
ก็เป็นความรักของพี่กับน้องอาทำให้แอนนา
ปรับมานะครับเป็นคนปกติอ่า
อ๋อๆครับแล้วก็ช่วยกันเลขขับอ๋อไม่ใช่
ความรักแบบที่อ้าวไม่ใช่ความรักแบบที่
แต่งงานถ้าไม่ใช่
อ๋อไม่ใช่ผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงไม่ใช่
แต่ว่าเป็นของแอนนา 2 เอลซ่าของเป็นผู้
หญิงเหมือนกันในครับ
โอ๊ย 5 เย้แล้วขอทั้งคู่มาก็ก้อนรู้ว่า
ฮ้อนไม่ใช่คนดีก็ไล่หอนออกไปครับไลน์หอน
อายคอนเป็นคนไม่มีใจครับไม่เอาไล่อ่อนออก
ไปขอ
แล้วทุกคนก็กลับไปคิดมากกว้างด้วยกัน
อย่างมีความทุกข์นะครับขอ
เรียงคิดว่าสตีฟคือรักแท้ออกนาอา
โอ้นี่แม่ใจให้แน่ใจเหมือนกันอาจจะใช่ไม่
รู้ใช่ไหมคะไม่รู้ครับแต่ว่า
แอนนากับเอลซ่าก็คือรักแท้ใช่ครับอ่าเป็น
ที่เป็นน้องกันเป็นความรักแท้นะครับโอเค
อ่าเรื่องนี้ก็จบแล้วห่า
จบแล้วนะคะ
อ่ะอยากจะดูเรื่องนี้นะครับหรือเคยดูแล้ว
นะครับอ่ะที่คอมเม้นท์บอกเพียงตี้บอกน้อง
เรียมได้ว่าเคยดูแล้วเคยดูแล้วอ่าหรือยัง
ไม่เคยดู
แค่แล้วก็บอกพวกเราด้วยนะคะว่าชอบหรือไม่
ชอบถ้าใช่ครับชอบหรือไม่ชอบบอกเราด้วยนะ
ครับใช่เดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมาเจอกันใหม่นะ
ครับพี่อาร์ตี้กับน้องเรียมจะมีหนัง
เรื่องอะไรมันล่ะให้นักเรียนฟังอิน้ำสอบ
ไม่เจอกันไหนได้ใช่วันนี้มวยช่องอะไรคะ
พี่นัดเจอกันที่ท่องนี้ครับคอม frenzel
ไทยนะครับหายดูแล้วอย่าลืมกดไลค์และกด
Subscribe กด Share กดแชร์ด้วย
ไทยข่าววันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วหมดเวลาเลยกัน
ครั้งถัดไปค่ะใช่ครับโอเคอ่าสวัสดีครับนะ
ครับเดี๋ยวตีกับเรียมก็ลาไปก่อนสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบายสวัสดีครับน้องเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ